so this morning I caught a few minutes
of Dilbert creator Scott Adams
livestream which he does from I guess
his kitchen and he was saying how he
doesn't like how analogy is being used
to equate things that Trump has done or
said to things that are like for example
the Nazis well we don't have to use
analogy anymore because Donald Trump is
now using actual Nazi language to refer
to immigrants and his supporters are
just eating it up because they can
finally feel okay about harboring some
of these horrible beliefs about people
that are different from them and I'm
talking specifically about the word
infestation Donald Trump tweeted
yesterday Democrats are the problem they
don't care about crime and want illegal
immigrants no matter how bad they may be
to pour into and infest our country like
ms-13 they can't win on their terrible
policies so they view them as potential
votes and voters and as usual it's sort
of couched as if he might be talking
just about ms-13 members but the
language is always there and you'll
remember America first America first was
pseudo jingoistic but it referenced
horrible movements in this country's
past infestation is straight out of Nazi
language used to dehumanize Jews during
the Holocaust am I saying Trump is
Hitler no am i making an analogy of some
kind which scott adams apparently would
be displeased with no I'm saying he's
using the same language about Latino
immigrants that Hitler and the Nazis
used about Jews and back in the
Holocaust era Nazis would talk about
Jews as rats and vermin and how their
presence is an infestation and this is a
trend with Trump it's the the when you
look at the progression right there's
his classic which was something like I'm
paraphrasing they are sending their best
people they're sending the rapists and
the criminals and some I assume are good
people something like that
back in April I told you about Donald
Trump choosing to use the word breeding
when referring to Latino immigrants
having kids once again it's dehumanizing
language referencing animals and I don't
even believe for a second that trumps
coming up with this language on his own
I think that his vocabulary is being
seeded by someone at the White House
probably Stephen Miller but it doesn't
matter right because whether Trump is
coming up with it himself or he's
getting it from somebody else like
Stephen Miller its impact is the same
and when you look back in history at
major mass human rights violations what
precedes them is the dehumanization of
the targeted group and that
dehumanization starts as linguistic
dehumanization if you don't see them as
people or at least not people like us
then it's more likely that you will look
the other way when they're eventually
mistreated and the first colonizers of
the United States did it to Native
Americans the Nazis did it to the Jews
many other examples Ronda Bosnia this is
the pattern and I hate to break it to
everybody who's hearing me say this and
they're sort of hoping for or expecting
some Republican awakening around this
vile language it's not gonna happen
Pat he has been saying this stuff for a
long time and they voted for him anyway
they don't care about this language oh
they like it he's appealing to his
voters particularly lead the ones in the
Midwest in the West you know that Rust
Belt area those who live in rural
communities across the entire country
and many of those people they may not
know Hispanic person they may not know a
Muslim person and that's how he gets
away with it the only way that he will
not get away with it is if we vote them
out because the Republicans aren't going
to help and in addition to voting in
November November a few other ideas for
what you can do number one don't stop
emailing don't stop writing physical
letters don't stop calling your
representatives demand a bill to stop
the policies that are seeing kids
separated from their parents and put
into facto internment camps do not stop
talking about it on social media
the takeovers of websites that we saw
around net neutrality remember websites
darking out blacking out their normal
content on a particular day
support of net neutrality we should be
seeing the same thing around this issue
and there are also some organizations
that are working on this if you can
donate then do we're linking to a bunch
of those organizations in the
description to the YouTube video for
this story and most importantly get
people registered to vote as many as you
can vote gov I gave some much more
complicated URL earlier in the week vote
gov vote gov will tell you exactly what
you need to do to get registered in your
state and get ready to vote in November
I'm worried that too many people are not
going to do it and I'm increasingly
worried about that and I'm being upfront
with you about that because hopefully
people will hear me and they'll say I
can't allow that to happen not only am I
going to vote I'm gonna get other people
to vote but I am increasingly scared
about the voter turnout from the left in
November I'm very worried that the
Democrats won't win back the Senate or
even the house and I guess we'll cross
that bridge once we get to it yes we got
to do it we got a we got a turnout what
we know is that there are many bridges
we will not be crossing in 2018 I'm
sorry in 2019 and 2020 if Democrats
don't take back the House and Senate in
November